foreign
[Music]
that singer facing charges of attempted
murder here in Las Vegas she is the same
person our a news now investigator
showed you in these videos claiming she
stabbed a man she met online in
retaliation for a U.S drone strike on an
Iranian military leader our eight news
now investigators have learned that
while on house arrest in another state
she's made music videos and also
performed for money
had police there asking questions 8 news
now investigator David charns with a
story you will only see here David well
we first told you Nika nakuben is
accused of stabbing a date inside a
Henderson hotel room to get revenge for
a military drone strike that killed an
Iranian leader she's under house arrest
in Texas but police there say they
weren't made aware
I just want to find a way
baby 22 year old Nika nakubin is an
aspiring musician with this video for
her song Spaceman I don't know I just
felt like somebody in the American
school has like should die because he
also died okay all right she's also
charged with attempted murder for
allegedly stabbing a man inside this
Henderson hotel room she's seen here on
body camera video talking to an officer
after reportedly stabbing her online
date in the neck just in general like I
mean he was killed so Imani that's a
flex bill so I feel like it's fair
enough
so the Cuban is on house arrest in Texas
she attends school and is allowed to
work but police there say they were
never told about it that is
immediate concerns for the safety of the
campus along the community a University
of Texas police representative telling
the court Monday they became concerned
while reading court records showing a
Henderson judge's determination last
year that nickubin was quote a danger to
the community we found out that no law
enforcement agency knew that she was
under house arrest
in our city or attending this the
university while a Justice Court Judge
set conditions like a curfew the officer
in Texas said the company monitoring her
was not holding her to those rules just
tracking her new kubin's attorney saying
her client has stayed out of trouble and
the music career is considered work
Chris does get paid for those events
that is Target for employment in
addition she doesn't
deployed in both ways but she does
attending singing event she gets paid
for them
now in addition to asking the court to
lessen to Cuban's house arrest while
awaiting trial her attorneys are trying
to get that attempted murder charge drop
saying their client did not intend to
kill that hearing was continued until
Wednesday I'm David Charles 8 news now
thank you David the Cuban has pleaded
not guilty a trial is scheduled for July